au Qatar ils n'ont pas pu porter de
brassard en soutient la communauté LGBT
plus car la FIFA est menacée de sanction
alors les footballeurs Allemands ont
trouvé la parade pour dénoncer la
censure ils ont mis leurs mains devant
la bouche juste avant leur match contre
le Japon regardez c'est cette belle
image le match ils l'ont perdu malgré
tout deux un sur les réseaux sociaux les
joueurs expliquent leur gestes nous
voulions utiliser le brassard One Love
pour prendre position en faveur de
valeur que nous défendons la diversité
et le respect mutuel au même moment
Tribuno officiel la ministre de
l'Intérieur allemandes Nancy Fraser à
côté d'Infantino en fil le brassard
inclusive One Love avec
l'arc-en-ciel bon Infantino c'est pas
bien il a l'air très joué on sait pas
bien si il voit bien le brassard à ce
moment-là mais enfin la photo quand même
est frappante ensuite elle a mis une
veste et hier lors du match Danemark
Tunisie cette fois quelle particularité
avait l'ex ministre de la même robe que
Joël plus ou moins dans l'esprit c'est
ça
voilà on va le voir en photo elle avait
une robe donc au drapeau arc-en-ciel qui
rappelle le drapeau LGBT et donc elle
elle a eu accès au stade quand dans le
même temps des supporters disons lambda
ce sont vues empêchés d'entrer avec par
exemple des bobs multicolores ou autres
signes LGBT les supporteurs ne manquent
pas d'inventivité pour tenter de percer
la censure comme celui-ci et ses
éblouissantes chaussettes un journaliste
danois a eu lieu des problèmes en
portant le fameux brassard One Love
troisième temps la diffusion par la
Fédération allemande n'a communiqué
cinglant qui fait honte à toutes les
autres fédérations c'est-à-dire celles
qui sont couchées je cite il ne s'agit
pas d'un message politique les droits
humains ne sont pas négociables nous
interdire de porter le brassard c'est de
nous interdire de parler la FIFA l'heure
où je vous parle on a toujours pas réagi
à cette rébellion allemande ça lui est
parlé danois et par les Néerlandais de
certains joueurs ont contourné
l'interdiction du brassard avec ses
crampons arc-en-ciel le bras n'a jamais
été aussi politique
j'ai pas vu une seule personne pas
déguisée au moins avec un nez rouge ou
une perruque où ça que c'était joyeuse
et coloré j'ai pas très beau donc ça
avait été un peu de soleil j'ai trouvé
ça cool moi les supporters qui se
réveillent quand l'opération est gagné
ça m'intéresse pas du tout donc je pense
qu'il faut rester neutre droit dans ses
bottes vous voyez ce que je veux dire et
en fait c'est pas dur d'être français
vous voyez c'est pas dur suffit de
savoir s'adapter un petit peu
on va la gagner cette coupe du monde moi
je te le dis hein magnifique Thomas les
ours polaires sont les premières
victimes du réchauffement climatique
au Pôle Nord la température se réchauffe
trois fois plus vite que dans le reste
du monde et entraîne la fonte des glaces
l'espèce toute entière était condamnée à
disparaître fan de foot Baptiste 17 ans
essaie de garder la tête froide le plus
dur reste à faire on va voir déjà contre
le Danemark comment il se débrouille et
ensuite on pourra on pourra penser à la
suite c'est pour ça qu'il faut
s'enflammer parce que il y a quand même
derrière je pense que c'est pas assez
solide on n'est pas forcément l'équipe
favorite pour ce mondial mais le
Danemark ne fait pas peur à Brian le
Danemark ils nous ont battus mais là
maintenant on va prouver que sinon on va
gagner le match les ours vont procéder à
une surprenante migration pour leur
survie et rejoindre au terme d'un long
voyage une nouvelle terre promise un
nouvel eldorado leur nouvelle maison
à
bonsoir Julien oui excusez-moi on change
les piles est-ce que vous avez vu un
match
je vais tout à fait honnête avec vous
Julien on a pas eu la chance d'être dans
le stade ce soir c'est pas vrai tout
simplement problème de billet et donc
nous avons vu comme vous absolument
comme vous le match à la télé et bah ça
valait le coup de l'envoyer au Qatar les
qatari ont créé une atmosphère parfaite
pour permettre à la faune polaire de
prospérer ici le réchauffement
climatique est déjà plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir le
Qatar première terre d'accueil des ours
polaires du monde merci le rire le rire
c'est aussi la santé et bien c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on construit son amour on
construit son bonheur qu'on construit la
vie et moi pour ça tous les deux je vous
aime
rigolez faire des blagues participer aux
apéros entre collègues c'est le
leitmotiv de beaucoup de salariés
mais à Paris un employé d'un cabinet de
conseils avant plusieurs années et tes
réfractaires pour participer aux
différentes activités amusantes
proposées par son entreprise alors face
à ces refus répétés de ce joindre aux
apéros de dénoncer les excès et
d'adhérer aux valeurs fun de la société
l'employeur a tout simplement décidé de
se séparer de lui pour vous l'aventure
s'arrête là la justice a tranché ne pas
être fun au travail n'est pas un motif
de licenciement et ben voilà c'est
vachement bien pour Axel
de tous mais on peut pas le virer à
cause de ça
regardez comme il est rigolo
ne peut pas être licencié parce qu'il
n'est pas assez drôle c'est une
excellente nouvelle même si ma chronique
est nullissime je suis invirable et chez
nous en France la petite ouais ça va pas
bien pour cet homme qui va chez son
propre son ophtalmologue pour un
contrôle de routine et il ressort
aveugle du coup j'ai [ __ ] ma blague
malheureusement qu'il est pas allé chez
son proctologue mais si je le dis avant
ça il est moins drôle ah je te de loin
toi téléspectateurs un peu ronds prêts à
déjà à commenter sur les réseaux sociaux
le débit de ma parole est bien garde
tant mon enfant car cette jeune beauté
ayant compris mon verre bien te prouve
par la même qui ne font point se
plaindre mais se taire